we bring in though our new colleague
foxnews contributor former White House
press secretary
Sarah Sanders look you did a job that
for me would be impossible I couldn't do
it
you know without probably going full
Anthony scaramouche II on them which is
a compliment I like that
but in all seriousness this is now you
dealt with the Democratic Party agenda
advance by a corrupt media conspiracy
theories lies breathless hysterical
reporting and it's always wrong they got
the whole thing wrong we got it right
that a little old talk-show host on TV
gee we kind of figured it out when they
didn't we don't we didn't follow the mob
and as a result we were able to get the
truth to the American people is now is
getting confirmed more and more every
day absolutely a first shot I think you
would have done great in my job and I
don't think the media would have liked
it very much because I think you would
have embarrassed them on the daily basis
so and I'm thankful that spacious a job
you know and then they doubted you bake
pies you bring them in pies and say I
baked them and they still say that I
don't know if she baked us I mean you
can't win I think it shows exactly one
of the biggest problems that the media
has is they want to question everybody
else's credibility when the whole world
is doubting there's the agenda of
obstruction that they have against this
president is completely out of control
they tried to destroy the president
because they hate that he won in 2016
and then they hated that he was able to
start delivering on all the things that
he said he was going to including a
conservative Court they hate the idea
that he is building not just great
things that are happening that are
taking place under this term but he is
building a legacy that will live on long
after he is no longer president through
the nominees and the people that have
been confirmed to the courts across the
country including two Supreme Court
justices because they can't beat him now
they're going after everyone around him
everyone associated with him and they're
even making stuff up is completely out
of control and at some point they have
to start holding people accountable I
think
the president's right to start calling
for something to be done they continue
to make things up I mean last week you
had CNN make up this absurd story about
a CIA operative you had Politico make up
a story about the airforce rerouting
planes to Venice that the president this
week you have the New York Times you
have three different major outlets and
the only thing that they have in common
is they're putting out fake news trying
to say it's true and that the review
question this in the way to take this
president down we got about a two-minute
warning or less that the president's
going to step onstage but I the
president's been very clear when he says
locked and loaded I would take it
seriously if I was a mullah and Iran
president does not want foreign
entanglements but the president
successfully beat the Caliphate back in
Syria Isis and he did it with superior
weaponry no boots on the ground or very
limited similarly I would not expect the
president to get involved in a foreign
entanglement with Iran but with that
said I don't think this president is
going to allow Iran to move forward and
dictate the free flow of oil at market
prices or disrupt that it's great for us
we're energy independent but of every
other country that we do business with
if they now are suffering because of
what's going on with the Iranians it's
not good for the world economy therefore
I would expect the president and I'm
hoping for Bibi Netanyahu whose victory
tomorrow I hope people in Israel vote la
cude we need his moral clarity he's a
Churchillian figure but on the world
stage but we this is now lying in the
sand and it appears they are now asking
to get hit and I believe the president
is very capable of doing what they want
absolutely I would certainly not test
this president unlike President Obama
President Trump is going to look in the
face of evil and he's going to say not
on my watch and he is not going to allow
them to continue to be the bullies of
the world and the president has been
very clear that he is not going to allow
that to happen we can't allow it to
happen
like you said thank God that we have
become an energy
independent nation under this president
but we cannot allow Iran to continue
acting in the way that they have for the
last several decades the way that they
continue to hurt countries across the
globe and I don't think that if I was
them I certainly wouldn't test this
president I think he's proven his
ability not just to fight back but fight
back harder than anything they think is
possible and I have full confidence in
the president and the team that he has
around him and secretary Pompeo and
others to make the right decision and I
know it'll be about protecting this
country and making sure that America
remains safe and that we remain energy
independent to things that are in
vitally important and two things that
he's been able to successfully do since
becoming president well the other issue
you know between the media mob and the
lies there's a very heavy price that I
would pay as a talk-show host now
everybody seems to think a talk-show
host only does opinion but no as a talk
show host we actually report news I can
produce thousands of hours of straight
news coverage where we're just asking
questions as events unfolding there's
war
there's hurricanes is it we do that we
investigated we did a deep dive on Obama
when the media wouldn't touch it we also
pointed out Obama's failed record after
eight years nobody would touch that but
also on the deep state you know for the
New York Times to suddenly admit
two-and-a-half-hour years late that oh
it looks like that dossier was rushed
likely Russian disinformation from the
beginning I'm like yeah you're only two
years and five thousand lies later
catching up to where we've been for a
long period of time but it's hurtful
because that's 99% of the media that's
why I called them the mob because they
have a mob mentality why is it so
personal for them and this president I
think because he continues to prove them
wrong every single time that they say
this president won't do something he
won't succeed he won't be able to do
anything on immigration he'll [ __ ]
the economy he won't rebuild the
military he won't create tax reform he
won't cut taxes every single time they
say he won't do it he does it and it
makes them embarrassed it makes them
look like fools and he continues to do
it
I think they're still mad that he won in
2016 and they're mad that he's winning
every single day for this country I
think it is incredibly sad that the
media and Democrats would rather see the
president failed in our country succeed
I hope that they will start to learn
from some of these major mistakes that
have happened over the last couple week
and start holding people accountable
start putting some checks and balances
go back to where we have a true
editorial process where they're checking
these things and stories aren't just
being pushed out in the prop in hopes
that they can tear somebody down but
that they're actually making sure that
their stories are right that they're
accurate let's hope that these learn
something from this if not I'm pretty
sure that this president will be happy
to point it out to them as well people
like yourself and others on this network